[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était pas bien c'est naze tu veux dans
la bouche non mais en plus j'adore cette
chanson jeudi
[Musique]
les espèces
m
yorick ont battu les mets je ne me
souviens pas avoir fait la corée n'ont
convaincu mais écoute
un petit 3 voilà merci à tous trois
barreaux
on va accueillir caroline lors ithurbide
c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
commentant de mouassa sa pièce coup sur
la tête de ma mère elle s'est pris pour
une faute sur l'arrivée mon frère a
glissé comme ça mais c'est facile c'est
sur un air latino
pourtant le tempo
ouah
le latino
est vrai toujours le champ de mars à
lille
sur un air latino d'abord parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui nous regardent aussi
ce soit parce qu'ils y alla crime qui
variait dans un instant hélas ces deux
salles deux ambiances jaune et rose la
crim travail touche énormément
ce sera avec nous dans un instant il va
démarrer des missions avec nous il est
magnifique merci combien vous mettez
alors que vous pouvez pour lui dire oui
il veut dire des choses très nette le
petit déhanché été pas mal hein oui mais
oui oui oui c'est lui qui restait mais
oui alors je mets un ainsi pas mal hein
bon je préfère vous le dire tout de
suite il y aura pierre ménès dans le
casting ce soir et on a hâte de le faire
faire le haut le voir faire lori ça
c'est sûr et certain pour le moment on
va enchaîner avec la positive attitude
et avec mon ami gilles verdez basique
[Musique]
c'est bon avec ça souffle tout fatale
merci au nom chaîne direct allez allez
ça suffit oh pas s'apaiser
je peux plus supporter aurait enlevé
moteur même perruque et calmez vous
qu'avez-vous merci on passe tout de
suite un maxime gagne c'est parti
[Musique]
je suis comme ça
moi
j'adore la souys - ventre héros un match
mais voilà on est fier de lui bien
traité dans son bien c'est toute mon
enfance et un 2002 album live et super
super regarder le courrier quand même
demain matin tacle oui quand même une
petite recherche au niveau de la
chorégraphie oui oui donc mais oui c'est
un beau nutr estime ferrer dans vos
oreilles comme moi là on va continuer
avec celle qui ressemble plus à laurie
tient notre djette székely laurie ces
particules
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les eaux par étaient tous en réalisation
est ce qu'on peut voir qu'il y au lieu
de voir ces images qu'on s'en fou mon
frère et on veut qui fait kelly en un
avion de chasse mon frère l'oréal secure
les attaques réveille-toi perron frérot
rêver c'est pas match de foot c'est pas
neymar mon frère parce que le gars et
réalise les matchs de boules d'habitude
fait nous qui fait arrête avec tes et 6
mai nous la recette puisque vous lis je
peux la refaire
alors franchement ce n'était pas pour
mais oui à tout le quartier
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
je pense que vous allez être pour
l'instant pour moi vous êtes la gagnante
vous allez vous mettre le connais parce
que peut-être que vous leur ferez pour
le plaisir et pour le kiff qui mettez
vous là aux côtés de lorie laurie qu'on
va vous lui mettez ce nom là que ça sur
la tenue de ces votes plaisir voilà oui
mais mais c'est c'est bon la seule qui
connaît les paroles par coeur depuis
début mai exactement ouais c'est la
seule qui a bossé ses notes
bon je vous doit d'accueillir il va
chanter la reprise de laurie du coup de
soleil permet laisse
[Applaudissements]
pas plus la nuit
elle est là
[Musique]
les divines et tongres a dit c'est qu'on
voit le gars qui vient abonder précise
quand même
il est en bas ça mais ma gueule même
schéma croisé encore sur le plateau n'a
fait en privé la [ __ ] au nord
bonjour laquelle il a prédit la consonne
adjabi tout bon état ça va pas ça me
déçoit les bonnes questions un besoin
les bonnes questions merci bien on verra
si tu vois tu pas doté comme
l'hôtellerie convaincu mais 5 c'est pas
mal c'est la moyenne c'est la moyenne
parce que il a fait un petit effort
oui oui attention choc des générations
maintenant fausses
j'adore ce choc des générations actives
et hop ça va isabelle laurie bon mini
boss
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais la bêta
[Applaudissements]
non
sortie d'un pack à plat comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la seule mais elle en fait elle
chante quand ya pas de mine mais elle
fait que je ne fais que dans sa bataille
comme à tout les jours et non la nature
est bien ce que tu peux nous le faire un
peu on a cappella comme ça à 20 ans à 20
ans on est un mari formidable
pas du tout ce qui va se passer après
offering vous entrez une toutes les deux
oui on a besoin de non pas du tout faux
nom et vous êtes magnifique isabelle
franchement j'aimerais en dire autant de
crédit il est jeune il est beau
j'avais donc que ce n'est pas jean
michel il a les cheveux tintin
d'ailleurs en embrassant me et il chante
à une de mes chansons préférées delory
ces deux reprises les divas du dancing
c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ensuite il plantera suffit catastrophe
avec catastrophe catastrophe aérienne
petit effort quand même imputé vendredi
ça raconte sans déconner si on tout cela
raconté comme ça moi je suis désolé j'ai
tenté en plus j'étais fan de laurie
quand j'étais petit bain vous êtes
toujours petit nom baba la note je la
mets c1
voilà c'est un c1 alors ils me disent ça
on terminera par jean luc lemoine parce
que vous savez que si tu savais que vous
avez qu'il a une tête à perruque
c'est un peu la meilleure amie de kanye
dans l'émission à gâteau proulx alors
attendez attendez comme la map se la
raconte elle prend pour une très grande
chanteuse elle veut chanter en acapulco
sans musique
en fait c'est déjà c'est déjà tout cela
j'ai apprise par coeur quand j'étais ado
des chansons que je tentais avec mes
copines donc hyper émue qu'elle soit là
ce soir est de chanter cette chanson
d'accord on savait que êtes en train
d'en garder tout le monde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez-y alors non c'est vrai et c'est
mignon franchement oui
allez on vous écoute et d'aller chanter
quoi tu va reconnaître les gens ce qu on
me parle autrement quand même hein j'ai
15 ans de bêtisiers d'agrément 15 ans ok
eyes est juste si tu vois ça qu'elle en
locaux le condo plonger sa 18h moi
j'aurais aimé des crustacés merci à
l'équipe ont démarré à l'est je serai là
toujours pour toi n'importe où quand tu
voudras je serai toujours la même un peu
bohème est interdite folie ce serait
même si la vie ne s'est pas celle qui te
redonne
ah les soirs ou ne doit rien au hasard
car tu sais que je resterai ta meilleure
amie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout
je sais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
selon bercy la bravo très belle
prestation
ouais nan franchement bravo et merci
merci faut pas rester là merci à une
note will not be amateur et on va
terminer par celui qui est le meilleur
chanteur d'entre nous il y aura les
quatre tirs d'ailleurs sa rubrique qui
sera là tout alors il ya camille combal
et jean luc lemoine ce soir un soir et
des ouf
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok
le conflit
[Applaudissements]
j'attaque ma mère ou sur twitter si vous
avez trouvé le meilleur un vrai
challenger florent pagny aussi si vous
[Applaudissements]
la note florent pagny de l'original tout
ce match non elle est plutôt sa merci
mais je lui ai alors les chéris vous
avez des meilleures notes pour laurie va
voir tout de suite les toute hausse vont
noter juste avant vous allez vous faire
une dernière prestation à 3 sur la
chanson que vous voulez à 3 d'accord
choyer ses quatre chansons de laurie ma
meilleure amie latino sur un air latino
toi tu es un petit peu la chef de groupe
oui c'est parti sur un air latino c'est
parti
[Musique]
y aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
quand tu veux
[Applaudissements]
la série c'est magnifique